[Music]
here's the line separating the us from
mexico
it's been a slow train coming for those
who want to cross it legally
and the pandemic has made things worse
with u.s immigration courts closed for
months
there are thousands of migrants stuck in
mexico who need them open to process
their asylum requests
the us has put them in a plan called mpp
which means they have to wait in mexico
while their asylum process plays out
even though they're from other countries
geraldo fled brazil he says because of
the threat of violence
he arrived in border city juarez 10
months ago
but is still waiting for his first court
date
it was for march 14 of this year but
that was changed because of the pandemic
to december 15th
now is for the 10th of may of next year
geraldo his son and his wife are
spending christmas in a shelter
many of the tens of thousands of people
that have been ordered to wait in mexico
in the mpp
program will be doing the same
some migration lawyers are worried that
they could miss the one year deadline to
start the asylum process altogether
louis torres hopes that's not the case
but she is concerned about the
well-being
of those she's trying to help
it's a complicated situation for their
health and basic needs
it's really uncertain what's going to
happen to them and that
generates anxiety just being here
waiting not knowing how to follow up
with the process
church is one of many along the border
which have been turned into shelters
he's seen hope among those now under his
care that a new u.s administration could
help them
i don't know who was happier about
biden's victory the americans or those
stuck here in the asylum process
because it means for them an end to
their stay in mexico so that they can
follow their dreams
president-elect joe biden had promised
to end the mpp
program on his first day in office now
his incoming administration
has signaled it will take more time and
there are questions
about what will then happen to those
spending this christmas in shelters
john holman al jazeera